let's find the limit of f of X times H
of X as X approaches zero all right and
we have graphical depictions of the
graphs y equals f of X and y equals H of
X and we know from our limit properties
that this is going to be the same thing
as the limit as X approaches 0 of f of X
x times the limit as X approaches 0 of H
of X and let's think about what each of
these are so let's first think about f
of X right over here so on f of X is X
approaches 0 notice the function itself
isn't defined there but we see when we
approach from the left we are
approaching the the function seems to be
approaching the value of negative 1
right over here and as we approach from
the right the function seems to be
approaching the value of of negative 1
so the limit here this limit here is
negative 1 as we approach from the left
we're approaching negative 1 superwatch
from the right the value of the function
seems to be approaching negative 1 now
what about H of X well H of X we have
down here as X approaches 0 as X
approaches 0 the function is defined at
x equals 0 it looks like it is equal to
1 and you could and the limit is also
equal to 1 we can see that as we
approach it from the left we are
approaching 1 as we approach from the
right we're approaching 1 as we approach
x equals 0 from the left we approach the
function approaches 1 as we approach x
equals 0 from the right the function
itself is approaching 1 and it makes
sense that the function is defined there
and the is defined at x equals 0 and the
limit as X approaches 0 is equal to the
same as the is equal to the value of the
function at that point because this is a
continuous function so this is this is 1
and so negative 1 times 1 is going to be
equal to is equal to negative 1 so that
is equal to negative 1 let's do one more
all right so these are both looks like
continuous functions so we have the
limit as X approaches 0 of H of X over G
of X so once again using our limit
properties this is going to be the same
thing as the limit of H of X as X
approaches 0 over the limit of G of X as
X approaches 0 now what's the limit of H
of X as X approaches 0 this is let's see
as we approach 0 from the left as we
approach x equals 0 from the left
our function seems to be approaching 4
and if you approach x equals 0 from the
right our function seems to be
approaching 4 and that's also what the
value of the function is at x equals 0
that makes sense because this is a
continuous function so the limit as we
approach x equals 0 should be the same
as the value of the function at x equals
0 so this top this is going to be 4 and
let's think about the limit of G of X is
x equals as X approaches 0 so from the
left it looks like as X approaches 0 the
value of the function is approaching 0
and as X approaches 0 from the right the
value of the function is also
approaching 0 which happens to also be
which also happens to be G of 0 G of 0
is also 0 and that makes sense that the
limit and the actual value of the
function at that point is the same
because it's continuous so this also is
0 but now we're in a strange situation
we have to take 4 and divide it by 0 so
this limit will not exist because we
can't take 4 and divide it by 0 so even
though the limit of H of X is x equals
as X approaches 0 exist and the limit of
G of X as X approaches 0 exists we can't
divide 4 by 0 so this whole entire limit
does not exist does does not exist and
actually if you were to plot H of X over
G of X if you were to plot that graph
you would see it even clearer that that
limit does not exist you would actually
be able to see it graphically